>>> THE INSURRECTIONIST IN CHIEF
IS BACK IN THE NEWS THIS WEEK.
YOU REMEMBER DONALD TRUMP AND
HIS MOTLEY CREW.
OR IS THAT MOTLEY COUP?
>> IT SHOULD BE THAT HE CAN
SIMPLY BE REINSTATED.
THAT A NEW INAUGURATION DATE IS
SET.
>> WASN'T JUST THE LIKES OF
SYDNEY POWELL.
TRUMP'S FORMER-NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER, MICHAEL FLYNN, APPEARED
TO ENDORSE A MILITARY COUP, LIKE
THE ONE IN MYANMAR.
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHY, WHAT
HAPPENED IN MIN-A-MAR CAN'T
HAPPEN HERE.
>> NO REASON.
I MEAN, IT SHOULD HAPPEN.
NO REASON.
>> IT'S MYANMAR, NOT MIN-A-MAR.
MYANMAR.
NEVER MIND.
FLYNN HAS, SINCE, BACKTRACKED ON
THIS BUT TRUMP HAS BEEN STIRRING
THIS POT FOR WEEKS.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY
INTERESTING TIME IN OUR COUNTRY.
>> IT WILL BE.
>> GOING TO BE A VERY
INTERESTING TIME.
YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT MEANS
BECAUSE IT WILL BE, YOU KNOW, I
MEAN, HOW DO YOU GOVERN WHEN YOU
LOST?
HOW DO YOU GOVERN WHEN YOU LOST?
>> SOUNDS LIKE HE WANTS TO GET
THE OLD MOB BACK TOGETHER,
AGAIN.
BUT, HOLD ON.
AS FOR THIS NOTION THAT TRUMP
COULD REASSUME THE PRESIDENCY,
ONE TRUMP ASSOCIATE TOLD ME,
TWIEZ ADVISERS HAVE BEEN
STRESSING IT'S NOT HAPPENING.
SPEAKING OF DESPERATE, I ALSO
SPOKE -- SPOKE WITH MIKE
LINDELL, THE MY-PILLOW GUY, WHO
HAS BEEN SPREADING THIS NONSENSE
THAT TRUMP WILL BE BACK IN
OFFICE, IN AUGUST.
LINDELL CLAIMS TRUMP GOT THE
IDEA FOR -- FROM HIM.
>> ALL THE EVIDENCE I HAVE.
EVERYTHING, IS GOING TO GO
BEFORE THE SUPREME COURT.
AND THE ELECTION OF 2020 IS
GOING BYE-BYE.
DONALD TRUMP WILL BE BACK IN
OFFICE IN AUGUST.
>> LINDELL WAS RECENTLY ON JIMMY
KIMMEL.
IT DID NOT GO WELL.
>> DO YOU REALLY UNDERSTAND THIS
STUFF?
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
>> LIKE, WHAT DOES -- DO YOU
KNOW WHAT AN IP ADDRESS IS?
>> YEAH, IP, AND THEN WE HAVE
THE I.D.s.
>> WHAT DOES IP STAND FOR?
DO YOU KNOW?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT STANDS
FOR.
>> I THINK THAT YOU SHOULD KNOW
WHAT IP STANDS FOR, IF YOU HAVE
EVIDENCE --
>> IT'S WHERE THE COMPUTERS ARE
AT.
WHEREVER THE IP ADDRESS IS OF
THE COMPUTERS.
I MEAN -- I MEAN --
>> SO, YOU ARE NOT AN EXPERT
WHEN IT COMES TO THIS STUFF?
>> DON'T HAVE TO BE.
WANT TO HEAR THE SAD THING?
LINDELL TOLD ME TRUMP CALLED HIM
AFTER THAT APPEARANCE TO TELL
HIM HOW WELL HE DID.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE TRUMP WISHES HE
HAD BEEN ON KIMMEL.
SAD.
BUT NOT AS SAD AS THE MAN, THE
MOB WANTED TO HANG ON JANUARY
6th, LETTING TRUMP OFF THE HOOK.
>> YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
I HAVE SPOKEN MANY TIMES SINCE
WE LEFT OFFICE.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL EVER
SEE EYE TO EYE ON THAT DAY.
BUT I WILL ALWAYS BE PROUD OF
WHAT WE ACCOMPLISHED, FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, OVER THE LAST
FOUR YEARS.
>> DON'T SEE EYE TO EYE?
AGREE TO DISAGREE.
ON AN INSURRECTION?
WHAT MAKES THIS SO DANGEROUS IS
THAT THIS COULD HAPPEN, AGAIN.
JUST LISTEN TO WHAT SOME TRUMP
SUPPORTERS ARE SAYING.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE LIKE
MYANMAR.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN MYANMAR.
THE MILITARY IS DOING THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATION.
AND AT THE RIGHT TIME, THEY'RE
GOING TO BE RESTORING THE
REPUBLIC WITH TRUMP AS
PRESIDENT.
>> IT'S MYANMAR.
ANYWAY, NOW, LARA TRUMP SAID ON
FOX SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHERE THIS
REINSTATEMENT STUFF IS COMING
FROM.
>> AS FAR AS I KNOW, THERE ARE
NO PLANS FOR DONALD TRUMP TO BE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE IN AUGUST.
MAYBE, THERE'S SOMETHING I DON'T
KNOW.
>> THANK GOODNESS, BECAUSE THERE
IS NO MECHANISM FOR TRUMP TO GET
REINSTATED.
THAT IS DELUSIONAL.
IF TRUMP REALLY BELIEVES HE WILL
BE BACK IN THE WHITE HOUSE, THIS
AUGUST, HE SHOULD GET HELP.
YOU ARE NOT WELL, SIR.
YOU NEED TO GET OVER THIS.
SAME GOES, FOR THE GOP.
IT'S AS IF MUCH OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS TRAPPED IN A
JIMMY-BUFFETT TUNE.
WASTING AWAY AGAIN IN
MAR-A-LAGOVILLE.
SOME PEOPLE CLAIM THAT THERE IS
AN ORANGE MAN TO BLAME, BUT I
KNOW IT'S MY OWN DAMN FAULT.
HEY.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT BEDMINSTER
RHAPSODY.
BUT I DIGRESS.
LISTEN.
TRUMP'S LIFE.
IT'S LIKE A COUNTRY-MUSIC SONG.
HE'S LOST THE HOUSE.
HE'S LOST THE SENATE.
HE'S LOST THE WHITE HOUSE.
HIS WEBSITE.
IF HE HAD A DOG, THE DOG WOULD
LEAVE HIM, TOO.
IF YOU'RE TRUMP, WHY NOT LET
AMERICA'S DEMOCRATIC
INSTITUTIONS BURN?
BUT PERHAPS, WHAT WE ARE
WITNESSING, THESE DAYS, IS MORE
OF A SLOW-MOTION COUP.
SOME-14 STATES HAVE ENACTED 22
NEW LAWS MAKING IT HARDER TO
VOTE SINCE TRUMP LOST.
THE SHAM AUDIT OF THE VOTES
CONTINUES IN ARIZONA.
SOME PENNSYLVANIA REPUBLICANS
FLEW THERE TO GET A CLOSER LOOK.
IN TEXAS, THE GOP WANTS TO
REVIVE THEIR RESTRICTIVE-VOTING
BILL.
MORE THAN 100 SCHOLARS SAID IT
BEST, THIS WEEK.
OUR DEMOCRACY IS FUNDAMENTALLY
AT STAKE.
HISTORY WILL JUDGE WHAT WE DO,
AT THIS MOMENT.
PLEASE, NO MORE ELECTI